hello imma be no Corrado the 2010
Massachusetts take geography be with it
if you were to travel to your time what
should they do why we are there you are
some local travel tips places to visit
things to see well for one you could
always go too low only 10 miles from
here and see Cardinals from 19th century
these started the industrial revolution
in America and greatly rebel to lies the
downtown area flow another thing to see
you would be the Charles River it has
great views of course of sidewalks and
in inner Boston it was through Boston
see doctors in the river are very
enjoyable editors are enjoyed by the
tourists but you can get splashed too
it's very entertaining at the same time
Heights and the mountains have always
been like a national pastime
Massachusetts investors with me along
the border of New Hampshire we have a
set of town especially the long
Merrimack River also modern near
wachusett reservoir called wachusett
mountain is a van a drunk or it's over
which means a single mountain then it's
not combined in a mountain range for
it's a single mountain on that mountain
are very many hiking trails which are
very scenic and are also enjoyed by many
tourists that come there to either ski
or hike what does green mean to you and
your prints of your age we understand
that going green means being
environmentally friendly friendly since
resources we consume either directly or
indirectly come from the earth being
aware of this cycle using them carefully
avoiding wasting them and using
more resources and renewable resources
wherever weekend is instrument let's say
you could play it basis if any famous
explorer are violated who would you pick
and why well first of all I will pick
Mahatma Gandhi because he was a leader
that could not be equaled he fought
against the British the most powerful
Empire in the world with non-violence
that's a great task nowadays it seems
that fine 13 countries can't solve be
solved with non-violence they can only
be solved with finals but we should
strive to achieve world peace and work
towards it even in times of war if
someone gave you a plea to get your
cloud anywhere in the world where would
you go tell us what you would do while
you were there and why you picked it
first gonna travel books would be
Western here I've always been fascinated
and I haven't gone in yet I would love
to see Paris for the Eiffel Tower and
the Louvre I would love to see Pisa for
the Leaning Tower of Pisa and the UK for
things like Buckingham Palace and
downing some sweet and Westminster
buildings these are all national
monuments or some sort of tourist
attraction that have been a source of
income for all these countries that's
what economical geographies link to them
and I would like to visit them to Howard
is much all with information and
knowledge into your brain what's the
secret shaving off your study tips of
tricks um what I hear a question I
remember it easily so I suggest to all
be serious contestants you should have
someone in your family you should add
employment you should ask them to read
over the question for you many times and
you answer it
many multiple times before anything that
should be on your to-do list if you put
you in charge of the for the entire day
come on just written this job at this
was the very first problem or issue you
tackle what will you do well I've been
thinking about this and I never
denounced two things poverty or global
warming since global warning and new
technology interests me more I would
pick that nothing poverty is not
important poverty on the other hand
there's so many people that live in
poverty we can all help donate to
charity and help them out because
they're struggling to live day to day
life global warming if I was in charge
of the earth I would immediately right
global warming I could change the law
from how an only having cars of hydrogen
fuel cells are solar powered cars and
then factory wigglies would have to be
water vapor instead of this harmful
smoke or smog in the atmosphere that
have been harming our planes to this day
hey nice video did you know try to stomp
on Sharon beard but through our random
fact you have done the top the toilet
paper capital of the world is in which
city which is female descansen thank you
you